hey new kid your fancy clothes may play
well in a big city like carolina but
here in new england we dress like
ignore him dude pretends he has a long
distance friend
tom israel he lives in tampa shine
through the shade baby i just dance
if cam dances he should be covered in
chowder and thrown in the harbor
man what haven't you listened to the
radio new england has banned
dancing so the patriot way is when we
play a game but hey playing it well
gronk was allowed to have fun because he
was why
we were winning and other transfer
students know how to deal with this
relax
everyone there's enough targets to go
around
stay away from my team fools all right
i'll be here when you need me you'll
never be my real dad but i'll be the
best [ __ ] stepdad you ever had
i know what we need a black and white
train in
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
this instagram good this gives dedham
some more time to develop
[Music]
okay and one more thing i'm sick of
these new york comedy writers and their
internet cartoons that make fun of my
people
why would i subscribe to this garbage
when i got boston sports radio playing
24 7 and the kelly's roast beef on route
1
and another thing when it gets cold in
foxboro the psi of a football goes down
talk to a professor at mit